we're continuing our look at the topic
of mechanics within mathematics
extension 2.
and just to remind you kinematics is all
about how
things are moving but doesn't really
worry about what the causes
for those different movements are
whereas mechanics is about
why what are the forces acting upon an
object that might influence in one
direction
or another so today we're going to have
a think about concurrent
forces which is where you've got a
single object a particle a body
and it's being acted on in multiple
different directions and
particularly today we're going to have a
look at objects under equilibrium so
all of the objects forces are going to
sort of balance out nicely
with each other so let's have a look at
two really simple examples that are
going to feel a lot like
mathematics extension one type examples
uh throughout today all the examples
we're gonna have a look at being in
equilibrium will
sort of be reminiscent of that but this
the thinking that we're gonna develop
today is kind of gonna
pave the way for the thinking that we
have for when objects are not in
equilibrium and all the cool stuff they
do there
that's what extension two explores so
let's think as promised add some pretty
simple
examples imagine an object here i've got
my particle
represented here with this fat little
dot in the center
and imagine it's being acted on by four
forces one
in uh the north direction then east then
south and west and they're all
one newton that's the uh the force the
magnitude of the force being acted upon
in each direction
now in this case it takes very little
intuition to say ah well obviously this
is an object that's going to be
in equilibrium but looking at a diagram
like this it's only because i've given
you such an artificially simple example
even if i make this just a little more
complicated not much more complicated
um you're going to see that our
intuition just by looking at a picture
is not going to be sufficient
say for example let's think about oopsie
daisy this diagram here
okay now you might say well this is not
more complicated it's less complicated
i've got fewer forces than i had before
but it's really to do with the angles
here right have a think about this with
me
um hopefully you can see that on a
horizontal basis left and right
this is a situation that is horizontally
balanced because
you've got this vector here which is
contributing nothing horizontally
and then you've got these two vectors
here which are or these two forces i
should say
which are symmetrical on a horizontal
basis so you know the same amount one is
in one direction and you can see they're
both
one newton uh forces here the same
amount is going in the opposite
direction so
horizontally everything looks nice and
balanced again our intuition helps us
here with symmetry
but vertically it's not quite so obvious
you know how much are they actually
pulling
in the downward direction do these two
evenly balance out with this one
it's going to depend on the angles if i
balance out these angles so they were
safe for example
closer to 120 rather closer to 90
degrees than 120 if for instance i did a
couple of vectors like
this you can see here if i had forces
that looked like this
they're hardly contributing anything in
the downward direction because
they're almost at horizontal so clearly
this vector up here
pulling upward is going to this force i
should say pulling upward is going to
take over
and i could do this situation in reverse
i could just as easily say what if i had
a pair of vectors
that were mostly pointing downwards this
will now look like a grossly
unfair game of tug of war right in this
case
there's not much horizontal action
happening it's balanced anyway
but more importantly they are both
virtually completely pulling in the down
direction
so it's like two people versus one in
that game of tug-of-war that i mentioned
so in each of these situations the first
one where this angle is closer to
90 than 120 and this kind of situation
where the angle is closer to
180 than 120 in both of these extreme
uh examples it's pretty obvious that
this would not be balanced
so therefore i have to say well can i do
better than just
guessing off the basis of the diagram
and hoping that i've drawn it
you know to scale enough that it looks
like it's right
the tool we're going to use the tool
we're going to introduce that will help
us understand both of these situations
and ones which are much more complicated
is one that we learned way back in
vectors thinking about
these vectors not as forces but as
displacements do you remember when we
were first thinking about vectors we
could say oh you've got a position
vector which means it starts from the
origin
or you could have a displacement vector
which could be anywhere and it just
takes you from one place
to another it displaces you that's what
the name says right
now these are not displacement vectors
they're force vectors
but if we think of them as displacement
vectors we can use some of that
geometric intuition
to draw some conclusions about these
scenarios and
again like i said help us think about
what happens when they're not in
equilibrium so
let's have a think about this one here
if i think about these four vectors not
as forces
but as displacements you can see fairly
quickly
i'm going to come to a conclusion as to
why this should be a situation
in equilibrium if i do the forces one
after the other so if i do the north one
then the east one then the south one
then the west one
as displacements watch what happens
first i start here at the origin
where the actual body is then i go north
and then after that if i just go
clockwise i'm going to go
east by one unit it's not a force
anymore so i'm not thinking of them as
newtons
then i'll do this southward vector and
then i'll finish up with this
west vector okay now in this situation
what i have created is a square
of course it's a square because i have
number one all of these
vectors being equal in magnitude but
also because they are the um
they're in the directions of a compass
rows everything is orthogonal and
perpendicular so therefore you've got
these four right angles
and that gives you a square and what
that means is
once i've returned back to the beginning
this is like a resultant
displacement a total displacement of
zero right you haven't gone anywhere
and that's the same as a resultant force
of zero in our original scenario and
that's in fact a really
important phrase a resultant force
and because we're talking in vector
terms
we will often denote that resultant
force with an r for
results it's equal to 0 because i've
ended back on the origin
now this is going to be really useful
it's much more useful in a situation
like this one down here
um the first example was super obvious
but this one not so much so watch what
happens
when we try and use the same reasoning
i'm going to start from the origin
and then i'm going to do the first
vector it actually doesn't matter which
one you do or what order you do them in
if i do the first vector i end up up
here and now i'll do the second vector
let's try and do this
quite neatly whoopsie daisy that was not
neatly
let's do this that's better and so i'll
do that
after doing this second motion so here's
the first one
then the second one now the thing i want
you to observe is that up here i've got
this 120 degrees measured
from the vertical but my vertical sort
of disappeared at least you know this
was my my reference point before that
original vector so what i'm going to do
just to help me keep things straight is
i'm going to place that
sort of vertical reference line back in
place
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to repeat this process for this
last vector
over here you can see it's going off 120
degrees and again
that's also measured from the vertical
because you can see that's where i did
it from in the first diagram
okay now what i've just pulled here i've
kind of taken advantage of the fact that
i drew this very accurately but i can
geometrically reason my way through
why i've created not a square but an
equilateral triangle not just it looks
equilateral but how can i know
well the first thing is sure you've got
your one one and one but you could
connect
three lines that all have a magnitude
one and not get an equilateral triangle
for example you know here you go there's
three lines that are all magnitude one
but i didn't get a triangle at all it's
all dependent on the angles
so therefore if i reason through the
angles here what can i see
well because i had this first one going
at 120 degrees
clockwise from the vertical and this
vector is vertical and then i extended
it to go up to give me my reference line
right
what that tells me is i've got an angle
in here which i know the magnitude of
because angles on a straight line
add up to 180 degrees so that gives me a
60
in there once i've done that i can
notice as well
that you know because this full angle
here is 120
um i can say because i've got a vertical
here and a vertical here these are
parallel lines right so therefore uh
this is not the only way i could reason
it but
there's 120 here and another angle here
in the corner that is co-interior
and co-interior angles on parallel lines
are supplementary you didn't think this
was going to be
all about a year a geometry did you or
you're 7 in fact
but sure enough there it is so these
angle properties are important
if that's 60 then i can see that the
difference between
this angle here and this one 120 take
away 60 that's going to give me
an interior angle that i can mark in 60
degrees
like so now this is fantastic because
i've got a 60 here
a 60 here and because i know what i'm
going to get inside here i know that's
why
i get this equilateral triangle so you
can see it's not just because my diagram
looked good
even though as you'll see the further we
go into this topic the more important it
will be to have a good looking accurate
diagram
i actually use geometric reasoning to
show this has to be equilateral just
like before
i get a resultant force r equals zero
okay so this idea of sort of
concatenating or stringing together
sequencing
vectors one after another like their
displacements even though they're
actually forces
this is what we're going to use this is
the tool we're going to use to help us
understand
these situations where you have a
situation that you know is in
equilibrium
or that you want to show that it is in
equilibrium so